Aquí tenemos cuatro moléculas diferentes,
y quiero que pienses que si tuvieras una
muestra pura de cada una, ¿cuál de esas muestras
puras tendría el punto de ebullición más alto,
cuál el segundo más alto, el tercero más alto y
el cuarto más alto? Pausa este video y trata de
resolverlo. Muy bien. En realidad esto se reduce
a cuál de estos tiene las fuerzas intermoleculares
más altas cuando está en estado líquido, porque
si tienes fuerzas intermoleculares altas,
tomaría mucha energía o un punto de ebullición
más alto para superar realmente esas fuerzas
intermoleculares y llegar a un estado gaseoso.
Así que pensemos en las fuerzas intermoleculares
que hemos estudiado. Comenzaré con enlaces de
hidrógeno, porque podrías ver que son realmente
las interacciones dipolo dipolo más fuertes, y
son más fuertes que las fuerzas de dispersión
de London. Podemos ver que el dietiléter
no formará enlaces de hidrógeno, no vemos
ningún enlace entre el hidrógeno y un oxígeno, un
nitrógeno o un flúor; el etanol tiene un enlace
oxígeno-hidrógeno; el metanol también tiene
un enlace oxígeno-hidrógeno; el agua tiene dos
enlaces oxígeno-hidrógeno. De modo que si tuviera
que clasificar según la contribución del enlace
de hidrógeno a las fuerzas intermoleculares,
pondría al agua como número 1, porque es la
que puede formar más enlaces de hidrógeno, pondría
metanol y etanol como un empate en segundo lugar
y luego pondría a dietiléter al final porque no
puede formar enlaces de hidrógeno. Así que con
sólo mirar esto sé que el agua tendrá el punto
de ebullición más alto, el dietiléter tendrá el
punto de ebullición más bajo. ¿Pero cuál será la
diferencia entre metanol y etanol? Y podríamos
pensar en otros tipos de fuerzas dipolares, pero
no mucho que puedas intuir con sólo mirarlos. En
realidad podría tener momentos dipolares similares
sobre una base molecular, pero podemos pensar en
las fuerzas de dispersión de London. Lo haré en un
color diferente: fuerzas de dispersión de London.
Voy a clasificarlos todos. Entonces las fuerzas
de dispersión de London son a cuán polarizable es
una molécula, lo que es proporcional a cuán grande
es su nube de electrones, lo que es proporcional
a su masa molar; y está claro que el dietiléter
tiene la masa molar más alta, seguido del etanol,
seguido del metanol, seguido del agua. ¿Cómo lo
supe? Bueno, literalmente puedes quitar átomos del
dietiléter para obtener un etanol, y literalmente
puedes quitar átomos del etanol para obtener un
metanol, y literalmente puedes quitar átomos del
metanol para obtener agua. Así que sabemos que
este es el orden de la masa molar, y así las
fuerzas de dispersión de London no harán que
cambie la clasificación entre agua o dietiléter,
porque esos van a ser mucho más débiles que estos
enlaces de hidrógeno. Pero pueden ser útiles para
el desempate entre etanol y metanol. De modo que
mi clasificación general en puntos de ebullición
es la siguiente: el punto de ebullición más alto
que pondría sería agua, seguido por el etanol que
ganó el desempate, después el metanol y luego el
punto de ebullición más bajo sería dietiléter.
Y si miramos los datos reales son consistentes
con lo que acabamos de decir: podemos ver
muy claramente que el agua tiene el punto de
ebullición más alto, el etanol es el segundo, el
metanol es el tercero y el dietiléter el cuarto,
completamente consistente con nuestra intuición.
Ahora, habrás notado que esto se llama presión de
vapor y también es interesante. Es posible que
también hayas notado que la presión de vapor
parece tener una tendencia opuesta al punto de
ebullición: las cosas que tienen un alto punto
de ebullición tienen una presión de vapor baja
y las cosas que tienen bajo punto de ebullición
tienen una presión de vapor alta. ¿De qué estamos
hablando cuando hablamos de la presión de vapor y
por qué vemos esta relación? No voy a profundizar
en la presión de vapor, habrá otros videos sobre
eso en Khan Academy; pero sólo para darte una
idea imagina un contenedor cerrado aquí. Y pongo
una muestra de una de estas moléculas en estado
líquido y voy a dibujar las moléculas. Claramente
no estoy dibujando a escala, estoy dibujando estos
pequeños círculos. La temperatura es importante,
así que digamos que esto está a 20°C. Ahora
puedes notar que 20°C es más bajo que todos
estos puntos de ebullición, de modo que en
su mayor parte estarán en estado líquido;
pero sabemos que no todas estas moléculas se
mueven con exactamente la misma energía cinética.
La temperatura se puede ver como una medida de
la energía cinética promedio de las moléculas,
pero todas chocan entre sí en diferentes
posiciones, con diferentes velocidades y,
por lo tanto, diferentes energías cinéticas.
Y de vez en cuando habrá una molécula que
tiene la posición correcta y la energía cinética
correcta para escapar y entrar en estado de vapor,
en un estado gaseoso. Y eso seguirá sucediendo,
pero entonces las cosas que están en estado
gaseoso de vez en cuando chocan entre ellas, y
chocan con los lados del contenedor, y de vez
en cuando podrían acercarse a la superficie con
la energía cinética y la posición correcta para
ser recapturados por las fuerzas intermoleculares
y entrar en un estado líquido. Y para que puedas
imaginar, esto seguirá sucediendo cuando las
cosas van del líquido al vapor, pero luego,
cuando ese vapor se eleva lo suficiente,
o podríamos decir que cuando la presión
de vapor se eleva lo suficiente -recuerda: esa
presión es por las moléculas de vapor rebotando-,
entonces llegará a alguna forma de equilibrio. Y
puedes imaginar que las cosas que tienen un punto
de ebullición más bajo, lo que significa que
tienen fuerzas intermoleculares más bajas, van
a formar más vapor, y entonces tendrás una mayor
presión de vapor antes de llegar al equilibrio.
Por otro lado, cuando hay fuerzas intermoleculares
altas, menos moléculas se van a separar,
de modo que habrá una presión de vapor más baja
cuando llegas a ese equilibrio. Y puedes ver eso
muy claramente aquí. Entonces lo dejaremos aquí.
Practicamos un poco y aprendimos un poco sobre la
presión de vapor y cómo se relaciona eso con las
fuerzas intermoleculares y punto de ebullición.